good morning Hank its - he's here how do
you like the poster behind you by the
way pretty cool a lot of ABS it's
question Tuesday the day that we answer
real questions from real nerdfighters
we're a little tired but we're gonna get
right to it how much do you love each
other oh yeah mmm I mean that's a lot of
question that's fine
Hank is there a secret code in the
building pages of an absolutely
remarkable thing there are these little
boxes and squares atop some of the
buildings and dashes in other places it
seemed intentional or am I just
overthinking this you're overthinking
that there are no Easter eggs at all
inside the enemy to say that what hey
John how do I vote in every state oh you
should probably look at Hank Green's
amazing project how to vote in every
state I so admire that like in the two
weeks before your book came out you were
working on how to vote in every state I
had a lot of help if you need to learn
how to register you need to know the
voting laws in your state you need help
understanding how to vote just check it
ballots all the stuff polling places
everything
Monica asks what's next for the two of
you bed what's John's favorite quote
from Hanks book and Hanks favorite quote
from John's book oh definitely my
favorite quote from your book is I had a
very happy childhood but I was not a
very happy child the one I stole from
you well I'll tell you my favorite quote
from a john green book yeah is it
mattering the future as a kind of
nostalgia which is really good and I
stole from my wife I did give Hank
permission I did I am for the record
yeah what character is in an absolutely
remarkable thing are you guys most
similar to April and Andy what do I want
to be most similar to April and Angie
there's some glitter on your face I'm
sorry oh it's from me it's been the
poster and I'm not going to apologize
for it alright well I'll just leave it
there also I was snuggling with Alice
and she is always just like covered in
glitter hey Hank
if you were a tortoise which one would
you be I think I'd be the kind that eats
a lot of carrots do you think there's
like some tortoises that some tortoises
think are really like hyper and fast
tortoises no yeah dude Larry chill yeah
got Larry enough we get it you can put
your head out of the show you can put
your head into the show yeah yeah like
like a whole care at this hour now that
you're both the author one what will be
your one word differential I'm the
science one
he's the old one who is better at
signing their name faster significantly
more attractive signature strawberry
jelly or blueberry jelly grape jelly
there's more glitter than some right
here
that's fine I mean it's part it's just
part of being Alice's dad
why isn't there absolutely remarkable
thing merch there is it's a dftba.com
what are you doing see how far I can go
just you know what goal this is it this
is the last shot of the video Oh Hank
I'll see you on Friday you're right yeah
oh hello there that wasn't actually the
last shot of the video greetings from
the future two things first even though
my part of the absolutely remarkable
thing tour has ended you should still go
see Hank he's great and secondly this
Sunday I will be profiled on the
American television show 60 minutes so
if you're interested you should check it
out
this is could Dragon Con 2018 it's just
about core strength Oh